I've been to a couple of NASCAR races
okay one of them was at Daytona I was so
disappointed you know why why they have
speakers
all around the track
so you don't get the pure sound of the
car moving from your left to your right
the speaker is giving you the sound of
the cars as they are not as they are
Doppler shifted towards you and away
from you wow so you actually missing the
most beautiful Doppler shift you could
possibly have and it's a 200 mile an
hour car screaming at you screaming at
you can you imagine how high that
frequency would be yeah at 200 miles an
hour and how low it would be going out
the other side and they got some loud
ass engines on that so you get the
airfoil noise the track noise and the
engine noise so I was so ready to just
feel the Doppler shift and it wasn't
there